20 عاما قضاياها رفيقيدر بن وسلاح خندق
واحد جمع الضابطين اللذين عمل جنبا الى
جنب في ميادين القتال قبل ان يخرق صمت
المماطله بالاتفاق رصاص اوقع وحده الصف
وارهق صداقه امتدت لعقدين من الزمن
ابن بادر بسيط
نشاته في قامت السودان كل منهما يتحذر من
مدرسه قتاليه مغيره صرامه عسكريه وتمرس
بمطارده الحركات المسلحه جمعت بينهما
ضرورات مرحليه تتقاطع مع ظروف حرب دارفور
عام 2003 فهناك كان اللقاء الاول بين عبد
الفتاح البرهان ومحمد حمدان دقلو
حينها كان البرهان ضابطا بسلاح المشاه في
مقاد احمدتي عشرات المسلحين لحمايه
الاهالي وقوافل لتجارتهم التجازم تقاسم
مهامه وذخيره صعدت بعدها العلاقه تدريجيا
وان عن بعد قبل ان يدور الزمن ويعيدهما
لصداره المشهد عام 2019
تحالف عسكري سياسي هذه المره بهدف اسقاط
حكم البشير تحت ضغط الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
ليمتطيا معا صهوه فتره انتقاليه كان يؤمل
منها قياده البلاد نحو الديمقراطيه
مجلس عسكري له اخر عرف بمجلس السياده
الانتقاليه تراسهما تباعا البرهان منتقيا
في كل مره صديقه للنيابه عنه
هذه العلاقه ظلت خاليه من التشويش لحين
اصطدامها بحائط رمي المسؤوليه عن فض
اعتصام القياده عام 2019
فبرزت شروخ داخل المكون العسكري تلملمت
على الاقل ظاهريا حمدتي اي دام وصف
بانقلاب الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر ثم
تاسف عنه وامتعض من اعاده قائد الجيش
لعناصر النظام السابق للسلطه واتسعت
الفجوه اكثر مع توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي
والخلاف على جداول الزمنيه لدمج قوات
الدعم السريع بالقوات المسلحه خلاف عجزت
مسيره الشراكه الطويله عن احتوائه وبين
العشاء الاول في دارفور والعشاء الاخير في
الخرطومه ذابت القضيه مع محاوله الاسراع
بتذويب الدعم السريع داخل الجيش بصفه
نهائيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات